Speaker 1: Well, President Joe Biden flew down to
Florida yesterday and met with Republican Florida
Governor Ron DeSantis and they did a soda,
sort of assess the damage and comfort people
type of event after Hurricane Ian devastated
Florida. And I don't even want to deal in this
segment with Brian Desantis's hypocrisy where in
his previously in Congress voted against funding
for disasters like for superstorm Sandy in New
York and New Jersey and then is begging for
the money. And in Florida we've already talked
about that. That's not new ground. So I don't
want to focus on that. What I want to focus
on is how either I mean, listen, reluctantly,
reluctantly. Ron DeSantis praised Joe Biden and
the federal response to the hurricane, indicating
they gave us everything we asked for. Joe Biden
praised Ron DeSantis. And even though DeSantis
had a sour puss on his face the entire time. It
proves that these people can work together. And
on so many issues, there really shouldn't be any
disagreements. The disagreements are basically
contrived for the voters to feel as though my guy
is doing something. So anyway, let's look at a
couple of clips here. Here is Ron DeSantis again
with a scowl on his face and a sourpuss, saying
Biden's handled this fine, this general area.
Speaker 2: We were very fortunate to have good
coordination with White House and with FEMA. From
the very beginning of this, we declared a state
of emergency last Friday, September 23rd. This
wasn't even this was a disturbance out there by
Colombia. And then the next day, we got a major
disaster declaration approved by the president.
And we really appreciated that. And that
basically set off the massive mobilization that
we had ready to be able to respond to this storm.
Speaker 1: So thanks to Joe Biden, they were able
to do everything he felt they needed to do.
Speaker 2: As of now, there have been over
2500 rescues affect you. Okay.
Speaker 1: So there is DeSantis
sort of like, yeah, yeah, yeah, it was
all good. Here is more a praise to some
degree from Ron DeSantis of Joe Biden.
Speaker 2: And I think we've worked as
well across state, local and federal of
any disaster that I've seen. And so I want
to thank Administrator Criswell from FEMA for
being on the ground, being supportive and being
very responsive. I think one of the things
that you're seeing in this response, we are
cutting through the bureaucracy. We are cutting
through the red tape. Wow. And that's from a.
Speaker 1: Democratic president letting you
cut through all of the bureaucracy and red tape
to get you what you need. That's pretty good.
Speaker 2: Local government, state government
all the way up to the president.
So we appreciate the team effort.
Speaker 1: So there was like a really
strange feel to the entire thing. Here is
President Biden also praising DeSantis, which,
again, is fantastic. These seem like genuine,
genuine compliments. I think it's a great thing.
Speaker 3: I'm comfortable with the fact that
Biden got what I call I mean, I think you
heard. Potable philosophy. But you can. And on.
Speaker 1: That is so difficult to hear.
But Biden said he and DeSantis have worked
hand in glove. It's been great. He's
been dealing with the crisis. Well,
and then another just really interesting moment
here was when President Biden was praising
Governor Ron DeSantis and says one of the great
things that's happened here is we've recognized
there is such a thing called global warming.
Speaker 3: What the governor has done is pretty
remarkable in football. This is always what he's
done in terms of, you know, it's. You know, first
of all, the biggest thing the governors, John, and
some of the others have done is recognize what's
being called global warming. Right.
Speaker 2: The world is changing.
Speaker 1: Yeah. And dissent is not thrilled
to have to sit through that for sure. And the
reality is hurricane response is very different
under Biden than it was under Trump. Here is
Trump. You might remember shooting paper
towel rolls like their basketballs not long
after being very confused about whether Puerto
Ricans are American citizens in the context of
one hurricane response. Then he showed up and
shot paper towels like basketballs and it's
all fun and games for Donald Trump. So certainly
different now. Here is my my big takeaway on this.
This is a reminder that so much of the
partizanship really is contrived now. There's
two perspectives. One perspective on this would be
now the partizanship is real, and both Biden and
DeSantis have to kind of turn up their noses and
hold their breath and sort of praise each other
begrudgingly. DeSantis is definitely begrudging in
his praise of Biden, but not because I genuinely
think DeSantis is unwilling to praise Biden.
It's because he knows it's going to hurt him
with his voters if he praises Biden too much.
Biden, on the other hand, seems to be having
a grand old time with the fact that, Hey, guys,
listen, there was a time and Biden was involved
in politics when it was the case where it wasn't
controversial, that on something like a disaster
response and many other issues, even foreign
policy issues, in many cases Republicans and
Democrats are basically united and work together.
Biden actually is part of that era where that was
a thing. And so the takeaway for me is so much
of the nonsense that we deal with where, oh,
there's a pandemic, well, let's all band together
and just do the Oh, wait, you're not going to do
that. You're not going to do that. Okay, here we
have a foreign policy situation and let's just
all we're on the same page that Vladimir Putin
Oh, we're we're not on the same page. A lot of
it is completely contrived at our deficit, to our
dismay, as voters and the people, they could be
completely united and take out of the political
realm. So much of this stuff. So very interesting
to see it. And one particularly interesting
moment when Joe Biden dropped an F-bomb.